oh
[Musique]
depuis deux mois tous les matins de
victor se ressemblent il prépare un thé
et le prend en regardant les nouvelles
en provenance de hong kong dimanche des
policiers ont déployé une violence
jamais vue jusqu'ici cela me fait mal au
coeur dit il de voir cet homme blessé
cela aurait pu être moi victor et sa
famille ont un parcours typique de
canadiens venus de hong kong
ils font de nombreux allers-retours
entre leur ville natale et vancouver où
ils se sont installés il ya 20 ans à
l'époque on craignait le pire
hong kong venait d'être rétrocédée à la
chine après 155 ans de règne britannique
pour lyon kong
cette histoire qui les lie aux
démocraties occidentales fait d'une
nation distincte du reste de la chine
[Musique]
et oui depuis deux mois
victor veut plus souvent à la rencontre
de compatriotes qui partage ces
inquiétudes
son désir de faire sa part pour sauver
la démocratie hongkongaise
ces deux jeunes sont venus ou sont
revenus récemment à vancouver pour
étudier mais leur coeur et à hong kong
il essaie de se mobiliser pour contrer
la propagande chinoise jouer les
victoires participe à un forum sur la
crise en comme presque tous ici ont vu
les taux de la chine se resserrer au fil
des années joue elle a senti le besoin
de créer une nouvelle association
étudiante à vancouver afin de pouvoir
militer ouvertement en faveur de la
démocratie
cela veut dire combattre les campagnes
d'intimidation de pékin qui passent
parfois dans les associations
d'étudiants chinois à l'étranger
et cet homme ne disparaît pas
complètement un immigré au canada
la puissance du régime chinois lui donne
les moyens de faire taire ses critiques
ou qu'il soit selon ce spécialiste de la
chine cet ancien correspondant en asie
pendant 25 ans vient de publier une
enquête qui révèle l'ampleur des
campagnes d'infiltration et
d'intimidation de la chine au canada une
violation incontestable de la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés
spir jenilou travailler jusqu'à l'an
dernier dans le secteur financier en
comme son entreprise comme bien d'autres
a été acquise par une société d'état
chinoise pékin en voit de plus en plus
de ses fonctionnaires dans tous les
secteurs de l'économie
le gouvernement se transforme
graduellement en dictature 10000
ses parents toujours à ancône l'ont
envoyée à vancouver en 2015 après le
premier épisode de la révolution des
parapluies elle était allée visiter au
printemps dans le deuxième épisode a
éclaté 9 juin plus d'un million de
personnes paralyse la ville nous parlons
emilie assume les risques que cela
représente pour ses parents voilà même à
vancouver la marge de manoeuvre est
mince pour les hong kong et qui veulent
faire bouger les choses
six jeunes canadiens souhaiteraient que
leur nouveau gouvernement soit plus
alerte et réactif à l'importante
présence chinoise au canada qui est
selon lui une menace à nos libertés